the Joe Rogan experience I mean we live
in the weirdest time in terms of like
progressive ideology right dogma genders
a construct races a constructor and
bring it all down but not race is not a
construct because no one's been
successfully translational oh that's
true never never been pulled off even
remotely not even ninety Murphy on SNL
yeah but you can go black to white like
Dave Chappelle used to do it all the
time memories dude alright yeah the
crazy way yeah you could you could do
black to white nobody cares you used to
be able to white to Asian you can't do
that in the transformational you could
probably go Asian to white people really
hold on to this race thing why is that
why do we go along too well no I don't
know I don't know I think I don't look
at you as like I mean though I don't
know what you are you're just a tank
you know I'm mostly Italian Irish 1%
Asian 1.6 percent African see I don't
even have that I'm just like a [ __ ]
from America like I'm just American
black
well it's if you can't if you care that
much like varieties interesting I like
that people look cool like we were
talking about Blake Griffin mm-hmm like
it's interesting that there's a guy like
him out there yeah big ol giant dude six
foot ten albino looking probably all
kinds of [ __ ] inside of ones of [ __ ] but
I mean like when you meet a guy like
that you're like wow that's a different
type of person look how big he is yeah
yeah like Shaq like which comes around
UFC fighters yeah there's a photo of
Shaq and he was training at American Top
Team with my friend Dean Thomas and Dean
is like I guess teens like five-nine
five-ten and he's standing next to Shaq
and Shaq is standing next to Junior dos
Santos he used to be the heavyweight
champ it's like his child looks like
Shaq's child
cuz he's so small and Shaq still like
what seven foot like he has a trunk at
all he's [ __ ] he's a legitimate
gigantic human being
I mean he's [ __ ] huge I like the fact
that there's people that are that are
different it's cool it's interesting you
know the real problem is racism the real
problem is not not that there's variety
the variety parts interesting it's also
like me in this new racism you know like
there's so much of the the canceled
culture and then you know you can't
what you can't say and it's like that's
not scary racism like it used to be
right I think people are more scared
about the the silent racism than like
you know that over you know aggressive
racism you like the lynching in the 50s
and 40s and you know before well we all
know that that stuff happened less than
a hundred years ago which is why it's
scary when you see photographs like
those black-and-white photographs of the
families standing around why there's a
black guy hanging from a tree month yeah
and then like that that is not that long
ago no so that that [ __ ] is still in the
air down there yeah but now this new
racism is like you know you can't you
can't talk about trans kids you know
well that's not racism but yeah it's
it's well it that's just what that is is
authoritarianism they're just trying to
enforce a certain way of thinking and
behaving and they they go hard on
anybody who deviates poor old Mario
Lopez nicest guy that's ever lived
doesn't have a [ __ ] controversial
bone in his body he's like well I don't
think kids should be trans I mean
they're little babies now like what you
insensitive is because they can go after
him for something like that and he'll
acquiesce Kuehl give in that's almost
like backing into like that old
segregative uh like I guess like you
know Jim Crow thing I remember like well
another blanket on my Emmett Till but
number one Emmett Till gets killed rice
because of you know he's doing a he's
saying hey you look kind of pretty or
he's a he's doing a cat call to a lady
right and then this woman goes and tells
these group of dudes just like hey and
they're just like oh we gotta cancel
Emmett Till you know what I mean so it's
it's almost it's almost the same thing
I'm not saying it's that you know
aggressive and violent but it's it's the
same thing of like you can't say
anything you can't have a brain I guess
there's a there's I want to say I get
criminal thought now I mean having a
thought right there's thoughtcrime yeah
yeah I mean that's the or well [ __ ]
right this is what people are deeply
concerned about its authoritarian
reinforcement of their own particular
way of thinking and behaving and it's
because people have the opportunity to
complain now like if if you just didn't
like the way someone addressed women or
someone you really didn't have a way to
broadcast it 20 years ago to select you
just but now anybody can just get on
Twitter or Facebook right and
it can go viral and a bunch of other
[ __ ] pink hair and weirdos will
retweet you and next thing you know
there's a goddamn mob after Mario Lopez
right I mean that's that's what happened
it's interesting though I mean it's it's
weird to watch it all take place
especially from our business because
comedy relies on taboos and in a lot of
ways like they're reinforcing us they're
helping us because people come to us for
relief yeah thank you yeah thank you
yeah keep the keep the PC culture going
honestly it's only making us more money
it's making us more accessible really
appreciated or has never been more PAC
oh yeah if people are coming in like
they're looking to hear those things oh
they're so happy with against the grain
when you go hard in the paint they go
crazy love it they love it yeah bring on
OJ bring him back
[Applause]